MARK GIORDANO.
COLLIN BLACKWELL W
REBOUND.
GET ANOTHER LOOK.
IN FRONT TRYING T PAINT.
HE FINDS HIM LATE.
HAS SCORED!
IT'SHAVOC.
BUT WHAT A SHOT.
GOOD TIMING FOR  NOW. THAT PUCK.
HE LIKES TO SHOOT IT.
DRIEDGER OUT OF POSITION.
HESCORING.
McCANN ON THE DOORSTEP AND THEY
SCORE! GOES RIGHTP WITH IT.
GIORDANO OUT OF THE  INVOLVED.
THIS IS A BIG BOUDREAU.
HE HAS A GOAL AND MAKE IT TWO.
JOHNNY GAUDREAU FINDS A HOCKEY
TIME.
MOVE IT BY
>> THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN ONE HECK
OF A A DID.
McCANN.
HE IS DEFENDED BY
TAKES CARE OF HIM ALONG THE FAR
BOARDS. A CHANGE.
HE FINDS HIS LINEMATE
McCANN.
TANEV.
PUT THIS ONE RIGHT UP OVER THE
IN FRONT.
DRIEDGER SHUTS AND IT'S
HOCKEY, S A LITTLE LATE ON THE
SLIDE.
A NICE FEED OVER FRO IT OUT.
TURNS BACK IN
SCORE.
AS ANDREW MANGIAPANE THE NET.
YOU HAVE A HIGH TIP AND A SCREEN
IN FRONT THEY SCORE.
I'LL TAKE IT ALL BACK.
IT'S ANOTHER NEW
CALGARY IS